Have you ever thought about how language can effect our thoughts or
perceptions? If you're like many of us, we often take language for granted. For
example, have you ever been in a situation where everybody else around you was
speaking a different language and you didn't understand? Or perhaps you've been
sick and lost your voice. You can appreciate how difficult it is to
communicate. However, we do have other ways to communicate. Such as through
gestures, writing or typing, or even american sign language. I'd like to you to
take a moment and think about what it would feel like, if you were in a
situation where everybody else was speaking a different language that you
didn't understand. Chances are you will feel isolated.